I used to just say [ __ ] out loud to
myself you know when I would feel the
dark cloud of doubt coming in I would
just [ __ ] that negative thought I know
you trying to become a better person you
know what you know to reach out for help
and all that I think my gut says you're
gonna be fine what you have to do in
general is when the doubt comes in you
gotta beat the [ __ ] out of it you know
yeah after the the biggest thing is is
that you're conscious that this of the
self-doubt so once you're conscious of
it you can then address it it's when you
when you're really young and you're not
conscious of it and that thought comes
in and then you start dwelling on it and
then it just washes over your whole body
and you can literally you know you have
a [ __ ] panic attack so what I would
say is you just baby step you wait you
know and like for me making it as a
comedian was like a 20-year [ __ ] 15
20 year process I was obviously I was
not the overnight I didn't have the hook
I didn't have any of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I just basically everyday you know
was [ __ ] hacking at the tree until it
came down and you know you just don't
quit you just that's it you just don't
quit you don't give it a negative
thought and every day you just [ __ ]
take a few steps towards it and then one
day just wake up and your way you wanted
to be and you're like eh how the [ __ ]
did that happen to you
funny you don't feel any different you
know so but you'll be alright thing
you're gonna be alright just say that to
yourself I'm gonna be fine this is gonna
work out and then that's it then you can
try to [ __ ] help somebody else out
along the way like your life is a bulk
you got a bunch of chapters in your book
but when they close that book
how good was the book how good was your
book what was the ending to your book if
the ending to my book can be so amazing
because of all that was done the money
all that was accomplished why can't I
create why can't I start why can't I be
a business why can't I be a CEO why
can't I be a tech guru why can't I
[ __ ] create cooking products lotion
since there's so much that some people
just don't understand they can do
because life doesn't happen to you it
happens for you so many of us choose our
path out of fear disguised as
practicality what we really want seems
impossibly out of reach and ridiculous
to expect so we never dare to ask the
universe for it I'm saying I'm the proof
that you can ask the universe for it
your job is not to figure out how it's
gonna happen for you but to open the
door in your head and when the door
opens in real life just walk through it
you are ready and able to do beautiful
things in this world and after you walk
through those doors today you will only
ever have two choices love or fear
choose love and don't ever let fear turn
you against your playful heart a man can
consider himself a success if he gets up
in the morning goes to bed at night and
in between does exactly what he wants
motivation books motivation seminars why
would anyone need to be motivated by
someone else I say if you lack
motivation a seminar isn't going to help
you what you really need is to be
smashed in the head 30 or 40 times with
a golf club
I had a [ __ ] motivate you or else at
least get you up and moving around the
room you know locate your socks [ __ ]
like that get the day rolling motivation
is [ __ ] if you ask me this country
could use a little less motivation the
people who are motivated the ones who
are causing all the trouble
stock swindlers serial killers child
molesters Christian conservatives these
people are highly motivated
[Applause]
and anyway I think motivation is
overrated you show me some lazy prick
who's lying around all day watching game
shows and stroking his penis and I'll
show you someone's not causing any
[ __ ] trouble